what are hand ranges and uh how do you
begin to estimate the range of hands
that your opponents have yeah so I
actually speaking to YouTube I did a
video on specifically this yes I'm
familiar with Rangers and essentially
you know back in my day the old days we
didn't talk about poker that way we're
like I think he's got this or I think
he's got that right uh nobody thought of
like the range of hands a player can
have so I guess the best example is
Imagine like all the potential hands as
being a part of a grid right
so the first player to act they could
have any one of those hands right anyone
randomly dealt right but let's say now
that that player raised to three
thousand dollars okay well you can
eliminate now from this grid a whole
bunch of hands that this player can no
longer have because if they had a two
and a three they wouldn't do that so you
can say okay he probably has a big pair
he has Ace King you know you've you've
narrowed the range of hands down right
now through every action on the Flop on
the turn and on the river based on the
decisions they make you narrow it down
even further so the range of hands is
the whole uh the entirety of all the
possibilities that this player you
believe could have and sometimes they
fool you or they have a hand that you
don't expect them to have in their range
and you know maybe a little bit uh
unorthodox doing some things you don't
expect to throw you off but a range is
essentially all the possibilities and it
Narrows as by the time before the Flop
it's endless player raises okay it's
minimized you now player bets the Flop
okay it's minimized further and then by
the river you know you can narrow it
down the entire range to you know just
maybe even a few hands is it always
shrinking or is there sort of as you get
surprised I mean it's always just an
estimate so is does it ever expand based
on sort of chaotic
unpredicted surprising behavior of the
players it really should never expand
the range of hands should always get
smaller right like again we start with
the the full the full scope and then you
should factor in like okay these are all
the possible hands you can have on the
Flop now right we can't have new hands
on the turn and if if you get to that
point where you think oh well maybe he
has this hand then you then you sort of
misjudged his range prior so you're not
thinking clearly it should always shrink
from the full scope to you know
hopefully just a couple well in that
video you'll also talk about it used to
be that you would play your hand but now
you're playing a range that you're
representing a range you're not even
just playing your hand so what does it
mean to represent a certain range yeah
so that's another big thing that's
different about poker from you know my
day to today is that back in our day we
would like put people on one hand like
you probably have King nine or you have
jax or something like that now people
are cognizant of the idea that you could
have an entire range of hands so then
you ask yourself in situations all right
I know what I have but what I could have
in his mind or my opponent's mind is any
one of these hands what would I do with
the entirety of these hands and so a lot
of people that are trying to play
optimally you know game three optimal
they think in terms of what their range
of hands would do rather than their very
specific hand
so is is bluffing in that context
essentially misrepresenting the range of
hands that you have no is that how you
think about it not exactly because so an
optimal range like if I bet the river if
I'm playing game three optimal a portion
of my range is going to be I have it I
got I got the best hand and a portion of
my range is going to be Bluffs and
they'll be balanced So in theory no
matter what you do okay no matter what
you do if you call or you fold in theory
it's just uh you're printing a zero as
we say you're not you're not getting
gaining or losing any EV if you were to
do it that way what's EV Eevee is
expected value right so every play that
you make you know it either is going to
in the long run you know make you some
money or it's it's just a losing play
and as a professional you try to make
the fewest amount of minus CV plays you
can and the only reason you would make
these minor CV plays is potentially if
you're trying to set up your opponent
for something later right so I might
make some minor CV plays right so that I
can exploit you later right so you're
building up building up an image a
player profile file that's false in some
way something that I'm going to I'm
going to plant seeds in your mind so
that I can exploit them later so for
example why would players like show a
big Bluff yeah like what would be the
reason for that they show a big Bluff so
that you know they're capable of it but
maybe in their mind they're never going
to do that again but now they think you
know he bluffed me last time maybe he's
doing it again but that's a what we call
like a level a leveling War because it
you know you can go back and forth with
whether or not okay this guy might know
that like he showed a bluff because he's
never going to Bluff me again so that
that's where it gets a little so that's
a little bit different though when we're
talking about hand ranges that's
different than
building up a mental model of what your
opponents what your opponents think of
you
and what your opponents think that you
think of them and and so on so forth are
you trying to construct those kinds of
method models and is that separate from
the hand ranges they go hand in hand
right so if any given in a given
situation right my range has this many
value hands and this many Bluffs okay so
in theory if I want to be balanced you
know this is my range and this is what
it looks like I'll bet this 50 of the
time bet this 50 time however if I know
that you think that I Bluff too much
right then I'm not going to Bluff as
much I'm going to start instead of
betting these hands that I would 50 50.
now what I'll do is I'll do like 70 30
where I'm basically value betting most
of the time against you you know or vice
versa if I know you always fold because
you think I have it I'm going to Veer
the other way and instead of bluffing 50
off 70 80 percent of the time to take
advantage of your perception of me